this video is sponsored by audible
listen to a free audiobook with the link
in the description every year about 60
million people visit mainland China from
around the world mostly to Shanghai
Beijing Guangzhou and Shenzhen these not
coincidentally are unofficially known as
tier 1 cities they have large urban
populations fast growing economies and
enough Starbucks to make you feel right
at home but this is only one of several
very different China's a trip to a tier
3 or 4 City or especially a village in
the country paints a whole different
picture for example just 15 miles
outside Beijing and its ninth tallest
building in the world lies a very
different kind of skyscraper piles and
piles of trash some eight or more
storeys tall here something like a
hundred and sixty thousand locals
collect sort and resell the city's
twenty five thousand tons of trash a day
entire communities revolve around and
survive on these landfills but look
closely and you might notice something
strange between the Chinese water
bottles tires and so on are say German
newspapers British grocery bags and
American milk jugs that's because for
decades China has been buying the
world's trash since 1988 it's imported
almost half of all plastic wastes the US
alone has sent thousands of containers
full of plastic every day then in 2017
China announced it didn't want any more
it's standards became so strict that
many countries suddenly had no place to
put their garbage
it all started piling up and fast in
western states like Washington Oregon
and California where Cycling had to be
sent to the dump
Ireland which had been sending 95% of
its plastic waste there experienced a
near crisis so why did China want your
trash in the first place and why is it
stopping now
it's hard to overstate how much the
economies of China and the United States
are connected unsurprisingly China is
the number one source of imports to the
US and it China's biggest customer every
week hundreds of container ships make
their way from Shanghai or Hong Kong
across the Pacific towards the American
West Coast they deliver your car your
sofa your dinner but as you also may
know the US doesn't have as much to send
back which means big scary negative
numbers and a lot of talk about soy
beans this would be a major problem
ships would have to make the two-week
return trip empty and thus double their
one-way prices making everything more
expensive imagine how inefficient it
would be if every airplane or car had to
return from its trip without passengers
oh wait that's just called uber the US
needs something to ship back to Asia
luckily there is something were really
good at producing a lot of trash
Americans make up only 4% of the world's
population but we generate 25% of the
world's garbage and dominate 90% of your
headlines you're welcome
on average each of us contributes four
point four pounds of waste a day for a
total of sixteen billion diapers two
billion razor blades and 220 million
tires a year it also doesn't help that
we order everything on Amazon and that
tiny pack of gum arrives in a four foot
box inside another giant box of course
in fact packaging takes up 1/3 of the
space of the average landfill which is
cool and all when it magically
disappears from your curb but not so
much when the city wants to build the
dump in your backyard anywhere but there
we Americans are great at buying stuff
and turning it into trash but not as
good at doing something with it
afterward high labor and transportation
costs make it quite expensive to drive
around the country to sort clean and
reprocess meanwhile China has plenty of
cheap labor and lots of demand for raw
materials they can manufacture new stuff
with plus we've already got a bunch of
humongous boats making the
at low capacity as the saying goes one
man's trash is another country's cheap
source of recyclable materials which may
or may not be environmentally
sustainable but we'll get to that in a
minute
thanks to good old supply and demand
shipping a 20-foot container from
Shanghai to Los Angeles might cost
$1,000 the other way for 500 here the
trade deficit works in our favor the
u.s. gets rid of its garbage and China
gets cheap materials to see how it works
let's look at San Francisco waste is
split into three separate bins compost
like vegetables grass and napkins
accounts for about 9 percent of all
municipal waste it's checked for
contaminants mixed and sent 60 miles
north to Vacaville California where it's
sold to farms and wineries as high
nutrient soil that's ideal but about
half of all waste is sent to the dump
it gets picked up sometimes move to a
temporary transfer station and then
hauled to a landfill where the plastic
bag you used for a few seconds between
the store and your car sits for a
thousand years not that you should feel
bad or anything the rest is mostly
recycling now sorting it can get pretty
expensive but it's hard enough to get
people to recycle anything much less
when you make them separate it so San
Francisco like many cities uses single
stream recycling everything from paper
to plastic metal and glass goes in a
single bin and then gets sorted at a
MuRF a materials recovery facility over
40 tons of waste is processed every hour
at the 200,000 square foot pier 96
tractors 2 piles of recycling onto
conveyer belts where it gets sorted by
humans mechanical dividers and optical
scanners apparently it's not uncommon
for people to recycle a bowling ball
finally the separated materials are sold
and shipped around the world sometimes
they move through several countries
making it hard to track exactly where it
all ends up for example Mexico sends
much of its plastic to the US and the US
exports mainly to China often through
Hong Kong so it's likely that even more
of our
trash than we think eventually ends up
in China after being shipped thousands
of miles across the Pacific eaten or
used thrown away collected and then
making the whole journey back much of
this trash will end up just a few miles
away from where it was first
manufactured in southern China and then
it'll be recycled and go through it all
again this is an extremely profitable
business it's even how John Young
nicknamed the queen of trash became one
of China's richest women it worked so
well in fact that nobody was prepared
for a world any different but that
started to change in 2013 with operation
green fence in which China announced it
would start enforcing quality standards
for imported trash then in 2017 the more
aggressive sounding national sword a
crackdown on illegal smuggling finally
the blue sky policy in 2018 added even
tougher restrictions and a plan to ban
all recyclable imports by 2020 for
months companies like rogue disposal and
recycling in Medford Oregon had no
choice but to dump recycling in
landfills which surprised is not a great
way to encourage more recycling since
then US exports to Thailand have
increased nearly 7,000 percent
along with Vietnam Indonesia Malaysia
and Taiwan but soon they too started
closing their doors
no one can or wants to replace China and
that isn't such a bad thing it may
actually be really good until now rich
countries have had no incentive not to
generate insane amounts of waste
actually it's been quite profitable this
could be a very good long-term wake-up
call despite complaints from the US
government China has no obligation to
import anyone's garbage like any export
trash is a product if demand changes so
must supply this is yet another sign of
China's great economic transition trash
is a remarkably good indicator of
economic health here's the amount of
trash generated by each country and
here's their GDP one of the reasons
China no longer wants
you're trash is that it now has plenty
of its own it's also part of Beijing's
push to lower its pollution and clear
its skies this year China is expected to
pass the US and become the largest
consumer market by 2030 it's expected to
generate three times as much waste as
the US and as China becomes more and
more important on the world stage all of
us will fall into two categories those
who understand it for whom this is a
great opportunity and those who are left
behind my favorite book for getting a
feel for what the country is really like
and where it may go in the future is
China in the 21st century by Jeffrey
Wasser strum I read it while researching
this video and I recommend it it's only
five hours long and you can listen to it
on audible let's be real we all have
busy lives and it's kind of hard to find
an hour or two during the day where you
can just sit down and read but it's easy
to just put on an audiobook on the way
to school or work or while doing chores
or writing long rambling YouTube
comments not that you guys would do that
what I like about this book in
particular is that it's a nice general
overview of China it doesn't pretend to
know the future and it doesn't have some
kind of agenda it's just a
straightforward objective explanation go
to audible.com slash poly matter or text
poly matter to 500 500 to start
listening to this book or whatever
you're into for free again that's
audible.com slash pol Y ma tter
or text pol ym8 e ter to five zero zero
five zero zero